[موسيقى]
في تركيا مشاهدينا اعلنت هيئه الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه تسجيل
1207 عشره ارتداديه منذ زلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب البلاد كما بينت هيئه الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه انه تم اجلاء اكثر من
ثمانيه وعشرين الف شخص من المناطق
الجنوبيه المتضرره من الزلازل واعلنت هيئه
بل اعلنت ايضا عن انتهاء اعمال انقاذ
المنكوبين من الزلزال في مدينه شانلي
اورفا معهد الزلازل التركي كان قد اعلن عن
هزه ارتداديه بقوه اربع درجات فاصله اثنين
في قهرمان مرعش مشاهدينا هذا وصلت ايضا
قبل ساعات البحث السعوديه المشاركه في
اغاثه متضرري زلزال الى مطار اضنه بتركيا
حيث كانت السعوديه اطلقت الجسر الجويه
لاغاثه المتضررين بدءا بطائرتين سعوديتين
اتجهت فجر اليوم الى مطار اضنه وهما
محملتان بمساعدات طبيه واغاثيه وعلامتها
ايضا فرق اسعاف وانقاذ متخصصه
الت الدولي مع ضحايا زلزال في تركيا
وسوريا حيث اعلنت عده دول فتح جسور جويه
لنقل المساعدات الانسانيه الحمله السعوديه
مشاهدينا لاغاثه متضرر الزلزال جمعت حتى
الان اكثر من مئه مليون ريال خلال اربع
وعشرين ساعه
الى سوريا مشاهدينا
حيث توجهت اليوم اولى المساعدات الانسانيه
الدوليه لسكان المناطق الشماليه الغربيه
من سوريا المتضرره جراء الزلزال عبر تركيا
وذلك حسب ما افادت وكاله رايتز ومن
المتوقع ان تعبر القافله الحدود اليوم
وتتكون مساعدات من ست شاحنات ياتي ذلك في
وقت اعلنت فيه الخارجيه التركيه عن انها
تعمل على فتح معبرين حدوديين اضافيين مع
سوريا لايصال امدادات الانسانيه وانها
تسعى لتسهيل لوصول المساعده الاجنبيه الى
سوريا
هذا واظهرت صور عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
نشرتها وكاله رويترز حجم الدمار الذي لحق
بمناطق واسعه جنوبيه تركيا وذلك من خلال
عمل مقارنات بين صوري العمران والبناء
السكني قبل وبعد زلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نتابع معكم اذا هذه الصور
المباشره لعمال الانقاذ وهم يجرون عمليات
البحث هذه الصور اذا من غازي عنتاب
التركيه
وعمليات البحث مستمره عن عجينه بين انقاض
هذه المباني التي تعرضت للانهيار سواء
الكلي او الجزئي بفعل هذا الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا صباح
الاثنين بقوه بلغت سبع درجات فاصله ثمانيه
على مقياس الاخضر هذه المساهمه مشاهدينا
دخلت كما اشرنا قبل قليل دخلت يوم الرابع
فيما تتضائل الاعمال تدريجيا في العثور عن
ناجين كما تفيد المعلومات
الوارده من مناطق الكوارث الاجماليه حتى
الان مشاهدين لعدد القتلى في البلدين
تجاوزت سته عشر الف
واربعمائه قتيل وفق حصيله جديده غير
هناك ايضا مخاوف من استمرار عدد القتلى في
الارتفاع بهذه الوتيره خاصه وان تقديرات
منظمه الصحه العالميه تشير الى ان اعداد
القتلى ربما تتجاوز العشرين
الفا قتيل
السلطات التركيه اعلنت ارتفاع عدد الضحايا
كما اشرنا ايضا في اراضيها الى
12,803 وسبعين قتيلا عدد الجرحى ايضا
تجاوز ثلاثه وستين الفا جريحه هذه اللحظه
فرق الاغاثه مشاهدينا كانت ايضا احصل
انهيار اكثر من سته الاف مبنى او ما يقارب
6000 مبنى في مختلف المناطق في تركيا
وما زالت اعداد العالقين كبيره تحت انقاض
هذه المباني المنهاره جهود الانقاذ هذه
ايضا مشاهده ايضا مع مشكله كبيره جدا
تعاني يعاني منها الاتراك حاليا وهي مساله
الهزات الابتداديه المتواصله وهي امتداد
طبعا للهزه الرئيسيه التي كانت في يوم
الاثنين الماضي
هيئه او اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
اكدت وقوع هزات ارتداديه اليوم في مدينتي
انطاكيا وايضا في قهرمان مرعش
مجموع الهزات الارتداديه حتى هذا اليوم
على مدى الايام اربعه الماضيه تجاوز الالف
ومئه هزه ارتداديه ايضا سوريا المنكوبه
مشاهدينا تعاني من وضع صعب جدا ارتفعت
حصيره الضحايا فيها لنحو
3400 قتيل في حصيره ايضا مرشحه للارتفاع
مع وجود عائلات مئات العائلات
بحسب المصادر الاعلاميه الوارده من هناك
تحدثت عن مئات العائلات ما زالوا تحت
الانقاض حتى هذه اللحظه مشاهدينا من
القامشلي ينضموا الينا مراسله العربيه
جماعه كاش اهلا بك جمعه والحديث يجري عن
حسب رؤيه
المساعدات الانسانيه التي ستصل الى الشمال
السوري في هذا اليوم هل من معلومات حول
الزمن في هذه المساعدات وما محتوى ايضا او
مضمون هذه المساعدات
يعني نحن نتحدث عن ساعات حتى تصل اولى
القوافل للمساعدات سواء المقدمه من هيئات
الامم المتحده او حتى من الدول العربيه
للوصول الى معبر باب السلامه والدخول الى
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا الاكثر تضررا في هذا
الزلزال يوم امس كنا نقول بان منتصف
النهار قد يشهد دخول الى هذه المساعدات
كنا نتحدث عن يعني مساعدات مقدمه من الامم
المتحده وايضا المساعدات مقدمه من الدول
العربيه الاسيمه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الطائرات وصلت الى مطارين داخل اراضي
تركيا لمطار غازيه عنتاب ومطار اضنه يعتقد
بان القوافل يعني تنزيلها وتحميلها
ستستغرق بعض الموافقات يعني الروتينيه من
الطرف التركي تحتاج الى بضع ساعات لتصل
الى معبر باب الهوى ومن ثم ادخالها الى
المناطق المنكوبه في شمال البلاد وتحديدا
الارياف ادلب وحلب
حيث ينتظر يعني الانقاذ بشكل كبير
محتوى هذه المساعدات هي مساعدات طبيه
وانسانيه المساعدات الطبيه مطلوبه في
المقام الاول وانت ليها المساعدات
الانسانيه وايضا فرق الانقاذ حيث يعتقد
بان يعني المساعدات المقدمه من الدول
العربيه سيكون معها يعني فرق انقاذ
لمساعده الدفاع المدني على رفع الانقاض
وانتشال
الاشخاص
وكانوا يعني احياء او حتى سرقوا الحياه
تابعنا اليوم معك مؤتمر الصحفية صبيحه هذا
اليوم
عن الاداره الكرديه الذاتيه بالتاكيد
واعلنوا عبره عن الارسال قواف المساعده
ايضا الى مناطق متضرره في الشمال السوري
هل بدات هذه المساعدات في التحرك هل
المعلومات الاضافيه حولها
نعم يعني المساعدات المقدمه من شمال شرق
سوريا من مناطق الاكراد مقسمه الى قسمين
هناك مساعدات رسميه
من ثلاثه اقسام القسم الاول شاحنات تحمل
عقود الوقود ستتجه الى المناطق حلب وشاحنه
تحمل مواد اغاثيه وطبيبيه ستتجه الى مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا يعني مناطق المعارضه هذه
يعني القوات الموجوده في معبر ام جلود
الفاصل بين مناطق الاكراد والمعارضه يعني
تحديدا بين منبج وبلده جرابلس كان لدينا
معلومات بان بعض من هذه الشاحنات بدا
بالدخول الى مناطق المعارضه يعني بدل
بدخول الى الى جرابلس لكن المصادر الكرديه
قال بانها بانها موجوده في نقطه الصفر
يعني على وشك الدخول ايضا هناك يعني حمله
تبرعات من المنظمات من الاهالي يعني
يقومون بالتبرع بالاموال
وسالون وجمعها وثم
سواء كان نقدا او يشترون فيها مواد اغاثيه
خاصه يعني الماكل والمشرب والمواد الطبيه
وثم ارسالها الى هذه المناطق يعني هذه
مساعدات داخليه من كثير من الحملات التي
شهدتها مناطق سواء داخل شمال غرب سوريا او
في مناطق النظام او حتى في مناطق الاكراد
هناك يعني حمله من المساعدات الشعبيه يعني
يتم جمع تبرعات ثم ارسالها الى المناطق
المنكوبه سواء في حلب او اللاذقيه او حمصه
او عفوا جبل او طرطوس او ارياف حلب
الناجون من هذه الاحداث جمعه ايضا كيف
يتعاطون مع مساله الايواء والسكن يعني هل
يقيمون في منازلهم في مخيمات
في مناطقها ربما تكون امنه حتى هذه اللحظه
يعني رغم انه الكثير من المنازل متصدعه
ويجب عدم العوده اليها لكن سكان خلال
الليالي يعني ثلاث الماضيه البارده جدا
جزء منهم عاد الى منازلهم خاصه مثلا في
عفرين عدو الى المنازل لان المركز المدينه
لم يكن متضرر بشكل كبير في الدب يعني معظم
السكان الذين الخوف الى المنازل لكن يعني
عشرات الالاف في المناطق والبلدات والقرى
المتضرره لا يزالون خارج المنازل جزء منه
في مراكز الايواء او في صلاه الرياض
الصلاه الرياضيه او عند
الاقارب او الاهل لكن جزء كبير الالاف لا
يزال ينام في العراء ودون فرصه حتى الوصول
الى الملاج او المقاول المؤقته او حتى
يعني لا يوجد لديهم اهل اقارب للجوء الى
منازلهم خاصه يعني المتضررين الذين تقدمت
منازلهم بشكل مباشر يعانون الامرين في
ظروف شتويه صعبه العدد الاكبر منهم ينام
في العراق طيب ايضا فرق الانقاذ التي تعمل
في منطقه في مناطق الشمال السوري جمعه
تسابق الزمن لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه وايضا
في ظروف صعبه جدا بهيه وربما انسانيه حتى
ما مستوى الخبرات التي تملكها هذه الفرق
الى اي مدى
الظروف المهنيه تساعدها والمعدات ايضا
يمكن ان تساعدها على تقليل حجم الكارثه
باي شكل من الاشكال يعني سوريا لم تكن قد
شهدت زلازل خلال العقود الماضيه وبالتالي
مستوى التحوط مثل هذه الازمات كان صفر
تقريبا لكن فرق الدفاع المدني مثلا في
مناطق المعارضه كان لديها خبره في التعامل
مع المباني المنهاره التي كانت تقصفها
طائرات النظام الطائرات
الروسيه لكن كانت تتعامل مع مبنى واحد او
منزل واحد مهدم الان هي تتعامل مع مئات
المنازل المهدمه وعدم ما يصعب مهمتها
لاسيما اذا عرفنا انها لا تمتلك الاليات
الثقيله او الجرافات او حتى الادوات
الصغيره التي يطلب من فريق الانقاذ ان
تمتلكها للتعامل مع مثل هذه
الكوارث خاصه تلك التي تحدد مثلا مواقع
يعني البشر داخل الانقاض او ليس لديها حتى
يعني مدربه للتعامل مع يعني
التعامل او الوصول الى الناجين او حتى
الجثث فبالتالي يعني هذا الفريق فريق
الانفاقسي سوى كان داخل مناطق النظام اول
المعارضه يعاني من مشاكل كبيره مشاكل في
الخبره وايضا مشاكل في الكويت
المطلوبه يعني مساعدتها في هذه المهمه
الشاقه بسبب يعني اتساع نطاق الدمار
والعدد الهائل من المباني المدمره طيب
جمعه سؤال اخيرا اللاجئون الفلسطينيون
ايضا
اثاره الكثير من التسارعات حول اوضاعهم
يوم امس وهناك اعداد كبيره منهم ربما
بالالاف ضرروا من هذه الاوضاع من هذه
الزلازل خاصه في وهم يقيمون الان في
المخيمات الخاصه باللاجئين السوريين ماذا
تعرف عن اوضاعهم ايضا جمعه
يعني هناك حوالي نصف مليون لاجئ فلسطيني
داخل سوريا وهؤلاء موجودون منذ وقود في
هذا البلد الذي استضافهم يعني طوال فتره
الازمه الفلسطينيه
تقدم مساعدات حوالي
473 الف منهم معظمهم كما تفضلت يعني كانوا
في مخيمات لكن مخيمات هم مع الوقت تطورت
اصبحت تشبه الاحياء السكنيه من ناحيه يعني
الخدمات وظروف المعيشه في هذا الزلزال قتل
عدد عدد غير معروف منهم لربما يعني يصل
العدد الى حوالي خمسين لا توجد اكبر ارقام
دقيقه وهذا ما صار مثلا يعني مخاوف الجانب
الفلسطيني من من ظروف هؤلاء هم يعانون مثل
السوريين من تداعيات هذا
الزلزال بعض من الطلاب الفلسطينيين الذين
كانوا يعني جامعه حلب او جامعه البعث في
حماه او اللاذق جامعه التشريف اللاذقيه
تركوا مقاعد دراسه وتركوا هذه مرحله
امتحانات تركوا الامتحانات وغادروا الى
دمشان هناك حوالي 200 طالب فلسطيني غادر
وهذه الجامعات الثلاثه المتضربه في المدن
المتضرره شكرا مدينه دمشق نعم
عكاشه مراسلنا من القامشلي شكرا جزيلا لك
في سوريا ايضا مشاهدينا كشفت وكاله رايتز
ان اول قافله مساعدات في طريقها الى
الحدود التركيه وستدخل شمال غرب سوريا
اليوم من جهتها قالت منظمه الخواد البيضاء
ان عدد ضحايا سيرتفع بشكل كبير بسبب وجود
مئات العائلات تحت الانقاض واكدت المنظمه
ان فرقاها تواصل عمليات الانقاذ وسط ظروف
صعبه جدا بعد خمس وسبعين ساعه على زلزال
كما كشفت ان عدد الابنيه المنهاره كليا في
شمال غرب سوريا ارتفع الى
418 فيما تجاوز عبد الابنيه المنهار جزئيا
حاجز 1300 مشيره الى ان الالاف المباني
تصدعت بسبب الزلزال من عمان مشاهدينا ينضم
الينا
والمناصره والتواصل في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا في لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه
انتم
كمؤسسه تعنى بالاغاثه ما هو دوركم في هذه
الكارثه التي حلت تركيا وسوريا
[موسيقى]
كانت تعمل في سوريا منذ عشر سنوات على
الاقل
ولدينا 400 موظف في
شمالي غربي سوريا وهم موجودين على الارض
ويحاولوا ان يقدموا استجابه سريعه وحمايه
ومساعدات طبيه ملحه
هل يحاولون تقديم المساعده ام انهم بداوا
فعلا تقديم المساعدات في هذه المناطق التي
اشرت اليها سيد مارك
و
[موسيقى]
موظفين هم من الناجين من
زلزال فقط استيقظوا يوم الاثنين
على وقع هذا الزلزال وكانوا يعملون على
ضمان سلامه الموظفين وتقييم الوضع
وبالتالي الان بداوا يسرعون من عمليه
الانقاذ والمساعده ليتمكنوا من اعاده
تقديم الخدمات من جديد بعد تاثرهم
بالزلزال ما طبيعه هذه الخدمات التي
سيقدموها للمتضررين من هذا الزلزال في
مناطق المعارضه السوريه
ان نقدم مساعده متكامله في سوريا وفي جنوب
تركيا
وغازي عنتاب كما تعرفون فهي مركز
الزلزال وتاريخيا كان لدينا مساعدات طبيه
نحن متخصصين بالمساعدات الطبيه
لنضمن وصول المساعده الطبيه لمعدم لمعظم
السكان وتقديم الادويه والان نحاول ان
نضاعف هذه المساعدات في الايام القادمه هل
سيء يتركز تواجدكم في مناطق الشمال او
شمال غرب سوريا كما تفضلت وهي مناطق
المعارضه ماذا عن المناطق الاخرى واعني
هنا مناطق سيطرت النظام السوري لكم تواجد
هناك ايضا
لدينا في شمال غربي وشرقي سوريا
وكل المنطقه تاثرت بشكل عنيف لهذا الزلزال
ومن المهم
ان ندرك ان الزلازل لا تحترم الحدود
وبالتالي نعمل على ضمان ان كل المناطق
المتاثره سواء في سوريا وتركيا
تحصل على المساعدات التي تحتاجها طيب من
معروفه ان سوريا تخضع مناطقها لاطراف
مختلفه ووحدات عسكريه متنوعه
ماذا عن مستوى التعاون الذي وجدتموه في
هذه المناطق لايصال مساعدتكم المتضررين
فاننا نعمل
الجمعيات المحليه ونحاول ان نضمن ان
المنظمات غير الحكميه المحليه
وشبه الحكوميه وغيرها نحول ان نصل اليها
لنقدم تضامنا في
مختلف
الطرق والسبل لتقديم المساعده للمناطق
المتاثره هل ترى ان هذه الجوده التي
تبتلونها الان كافيه لتقليل حجم الكارثه
على السوريين في هذه اللحظات هناك من
يتهمكم بالتقصير سيد مارك ما ردكم
[موسيقى]
اننا كلنا نخفق في المرحله الراحله
الراهنه فهذه مساله
مهمه ان ندرك اننا امام
زلزال
يشكل ظاهره غير مسبوقه وهو كارثي
وبالتالي
هناك مباني لم تتحمل هذه الضربه
وبالتالي اي احد وفي اي مكان يمكن ان
يعاني من ايصال المساعدات للمحتاجين اليها
الان اعتقد اننا يجب ان نقف امام معايير
عاليه ليس في منظمتنا لكن في مختلف
القطاعات المجتمع الدولي
وسلطات المحليه ونعمل
في لضمان ان من يحتاجون المساعده يحصلون
عليها ما قوله هو ان الجميع في منظمه ما
يعمل بكل الجهود الممكنه
وكوادرنا
يرمون في مدارس وفي سيارات وفي جوامع لانه
لم يتبقى لهم مركزا يعود اليه ولا
يستطيعون العوده الى بيوتهم
وياتون الى عملهم ليقدموا المساعده رغم
صعب الظروف والرغبه صعب الطرق المتضرره
بشكل كبير وتدمير الجسور
والمساعدات التي تقدم تاتي من المناطق
التركيه التي تاثرت ايضا بالزلزال طيب من
خلال تجربتكم في سوريا سيد مارك يعني هل
تعتقدون
هناك تسييس لهذه الازمه ام ان
الجانب الانساني والبعد الانساني يحظى
بالاولوي حاليا ما هو تقييمكم
الحقيقه
ان الجميع سيرى ان هذا الزلزال
على
كثير من الاطراف
سوى من خلفيات دينيه وعرقيه مختلفه
ولابد من وجود رد
اللي
يشمل الجميع ويتصل مساعدات لكل المناطق
بغض النظر عن خلفياتها وان تكون ايضا
الحدود مفتوحه بحيث تتمكن من ان نستجيب
بالشكل الكافي نحن كمجتمع دولي امل ان
نتضامن معهم وان نضع المبادئ الانسانيه
فوق السياسيه
يعني في هذه الازمه لكن لم تجبني بشكل
واضح هل هناك تسييس لهذه الازمه وفق ما
شاهدت
الوقت الراهن كلا في الحقيقه هي ان الجميع
يحاول ان يبذل اقصى جهوده لتقديم المساعده
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اظهر مقطع فيديو لحظه وصول جثث
السوريين الذين قتلوا في زلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب جنوبي تركيا وشماليه سوريا الى
معبر باب الهواء الحدودي
لا اله الا الله
[تصفيق]
كنا نياما عند حدوث الزلزال فجاه بدات
الاهتزازات على هذه الحاله استيقظنا احتضن
اطفالنا وقمنا بالركض ونحن ندعو الله كانت
الاهتزازات لا تنتهي حقيقه شيء يصعب شرحه
الله لا يبتلي احدا بهذا المصاب عندما
غادرنا البناء بدات الهزات الارتداديه بعد
عده دقائق حينها ركضنا في الشارع وكان
الجميع في حاله هلع كان شعورا سيئا للغايه
بانسى
عندما جلبت اقربائي من منطقه نورداك في
ولايه غاز عنتاب بعد حدوث الزلزال كان
امامنا ثلاث حافلات تقل الجيش والشرطه كان
هناك هطول الامطار والثلوج لذلك ساعدونا
في الوصول استغرق الطريق 16 ساعه علما انه
يستغرق عاده ساعتين
الا من ماردين وجئت لمساعده اصدقائي هنا
وانقاذ الناس ابني ايضا جاء معي للمساعده
وهو يعمل مع الاوراق المتطوعين انا اسكن
في الطابق الاول عند حدوث الزلزال خرجنا
الى الشارع بسرعه في منطقه ينيبي كان
مشهدا مخيفا
والد زوجه طيفون ايدوغان وزوجته عائشه
واولادهما ثلاثه كانوا يعيشون في هذا
المبنى وجميعهم تحت الانقاض حاليا
ان نتابع هذه الكلمه
ويهاجم الاسواق والمراكز التجاريه ويسرق
منها السلع
سيتم
هؤلاء مباشر
[موسيقى]
وندعم المواطنين الذين يدعمون العمليات
هنا بشكل مباشر نشكر الجميع طبعا اللام
نحن كنا متواجدين في مدينه ايفان واستطعنا
ان نتغلب على المسائل هناك
حصلت هناك كبيره جدا وجميع يعلم
الافات التي تلتها والحاله التي دلتها
وايضا استطعنا ان نتغلب على
الكارثه في ازمير ايضا استطعنا ان نبني
منازل ونسلمها الى اصحابها بعد الزلزال
لذلك
يجب علينا ان نتضمن ونعمل بشكل سريع وان
نعوض
المعتقد منازلها بمنازل اخرى شكرا جزيلا
مشاهدينا هذا جاري من كلمه الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان وقال فيها او تحدث فيها
عن ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى 14 الفا في
تركيا
وقال سنعمل ايضا على اعاده اعمار المناطق
المنكوبه بزلزال خلال عام وهناك من يسعى
ايضا الاستقلال هذه الازمه لحصد مكاسب
سياسيه مشاهدينا من ادي امانه تركيا ينضم
الينا مفرد العربيه محمود شكر اهلا بك
محمود كيف يبدو المشهد في اديمان هل يبدو
افضل حالا من بقيه المناطق التركيه
نعم عزيزي المشهد ينقسم الى جزئين الجزء
العصبي الذي كنا به منذ ساعات عديده وهو
في قلب المدينه وكان من المفترض ان تكون
الصور الحيه والبث المباشر من تلك الاحياء
الداخليه حيث ان الابنيه والمنازل هي سويت
على الارض المئات من الفرق للمتطوعين
والعمال الانقاذ الذين يعملون حتى هذه
الساعه منذ ايام عديده ولكن كما اشرت معك
الى اننا انتقلنا الى الباحه الخارجيه
للجامعه حيث ايضا كما نشاهد ورائي مجموعات
من الخيام للدفاع المدني الذي حضر من
ارمينيا في وسط المدينه او في المدينه
برمتها هي ايضا الى عده اقسام القسم
الداخلي والاساسي فيه هو سوي على الارض لا
ارقام دقيقه للضحايا لان كما اشرت معك منذ
ثلاثه ارباع الساعه كانت مجموعه من
المجموعات التي تعمل على رفع الانقاط قامت
باخراج حوالي عشر من الجثث كانوا في منزل
واحد في حين ان كل الصور او ان كل الاحياء
هي مقسمه على اجزاء اجزاء والجرافات وايضا
الثقيله التي هي متفرقه تعمل على قدم وساق
على عله او على امل ان يكون هنالك بعض من
الناجين اما في هذه المقلب هنا منطقه
لوجستيه هي
منذ ثلاثه ايام جهزت والحضور اليها للطعام
للمنامه وللفرق الاغاثه المحليه والتي
تاتي ايضا من محافظات اخرى او الدوليه كما
المخيم الذي وراءنا بالاضافه ايضا الى انه
هنالك كبيره لمساحات خارجيه شيدت عليها
الخيام باختصار المدينه برمتها من الابنيه
هي الجزء الاكبر منها اصبح على ارض الجزء
المتبقي منها غير صالح للسكن استطيع القول
من خلال المشاهدات التي استمرت لحوالي عشر
ساعات في هذا اليوم الى انه ليس هنالك اي
مواطن تركي يدخل الى شقته او ممكن له في
هذه المدينه ان يعود او يسكن اليها من
جديد المدينه برمتها هي في المخيمات التي
نصبت في الشوارع او على الاحياء او في
الاسواق او في الحدائق او حتى ايضا في
الطور التي كانت مخصصه للاطفال الدور
الخارجيه والاخطر من ذلك كله الى انه مع
الساعه العاشره ليلا من مساء الامس كانت
لا زالت الارتدادات للزلزال حتى ان هذه
المنطقه التي نحن فيها شعرنا ان الارض
تتحرك الخوف الاكبر من ان يعود هذا
الزلزال بشده اكبر ولكن كل الروايات تقول
انها لا زالت ارتدادات ووصلت الى العشرات
او الى المئات سنقوم بالجهد في المباشر
القادم ان نكون من الاحياء التي يقطنها
الجل الاكبر من السوريين في هذه المنطقه
والتي يرفعون الصوت فيها عن المطالبه بفرق
للدفاع المدني او بفرق لرفع العقاد لانه
كما وصل الينا الى ان عدد كبير من
العائلات لا زالت حتى هذه الساعه هي تحت
الابنيه وغير معروف مصيرها طيب محمود ايضا
لو تحدثنا عن المزاج الشعبي العام في
المنطقه
والتفاعل السكان وتقييمهم ايضا لمدى
استجابه السلطات
لاحتياجاته في هذه الازمه
معك بالتصنيف على حسب المشاهدات الى ان
الجزء الاكبر الذي بحاجه اليه المواطن
التركي او ايضا المقيم السوري هنا وان
يحصل على مبيتين يحصل على طعام يحصل على
مشروب يحصل على ماء يحصل على طبابه سريعه
هذا الذي شاهدناه ونشاهده هو وصل سريعا
وبكميات كبيره يعني الشاحنات الان نتحدث
معك مثلا مثل هذه الشاحنه اذا امكن
بكاميرا المصور وايضا خروج وخروج ودخول
المئات من الشاحنات التي تنقل الاطعمه
وتنقل ايضا المواد الغذائيه وتنقل العين
ايضا المقلب الثاني هو ان يكون هنالك مبيت
يعني المبيت هو الحاجه الضروريه والممحه
وهذا المبيت ان كان في الخيام او في
البيوت الجاهزه التي هي من البيوت
البلاستيكيه او قيم بلاستيكيه او البي
التي تصنع في المعامل وهذا ما يطالبون به
يعني
للربط ما بين المشهدين اذا امكننا هنا اذا
امكننا هنا كيف نشاهد هذا البراد الذي
يدخل الان وهو ينقل مواد اغاثيه وكيف
نشاهد هذه الشاحنه الكبيره والتي تنقل
منازل جاهزه ايضا لان
هذه الصوره هي تعبر كيف عن الطريقه التي
هي مكوكيه لعمليات الاغاثه هذه المنازل
الجاهزه التي بدات بالوصول الى هذه
المدينه من اجل ولكن كل الذي نقوله او
نتحدث به او الذين يحاولون ان كان مع
الحكومه او ضد الحكومه او مع الجماعات
جمعيات الاغاثيه او ضد الجامعات هذه مساله
يصح عزيزي ان تطبقها على زلزال ضرب شخص
3000 شخص على زلزال ضرب قريه قريه نحن
نتحدث انا في المنطقه التي مدينه برومتها
على الارض لذلك هي بحاجه الى عشرات الالاف
من
الرجال الارقام وبحاجه الى مئات الالاف من
الاطنان انت كيف يمكن لك ان تطعم مدينه
برمتها لا يمكن ان يؤمن لها الغذاء
والطعام والشراب ليس حتى اصلا يعني من عدم
الموضوعيه في العمل الميداني الاعلامي ان
نكون في هذا البسم في هذه المنطقه ولكن
الضروره لا يوجد كهرباء لا توجد نت لا
توجد غاز لا يوجد مازوت المدينه برمتها
مقطوعه عن العمل الخارجي لذلك بعض هذه
الخدمات الضروريه على سبيل المثال شبكه
الكهرباء هي بحاجه الى اشهر عديده لكي ان
يعاد ترميمها الغاز مقطوع ايضا الى اش
جديده كل الابنيه التي نرسل صور لها وبنات
بشوارب كاملها هي مرفوعه ومنصوبه هذه
الابنيه ولكن بحاجه الى
محمود تعاني منها اديان نعم اعتذر بك هذا
ما سمح به الوقت لك من تركيا كنت معنا
محمود شكرا لك
شكرا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من اضنا ينضم الينا زيدان مراسل
العربي اهلا بك زيدان ولو تنقل لنا اخر
مشاهداتك في اضنه وعمليات الانقاذ هل تسير
بشكل مطلوب زيدا
نعم احمد بالفعل عمليات الانقاذ في مع
دخولنا اليوم الرابع من هذه الكارثه
الكبيره التي ضربت جنوب تركيا عمليات
الانقاذ ما تزال مستمره لن اطيل الوقوف
امام الكاميرا سادع زميله المصور ينقلكم
الى هذا المشهد الذي وجدناه قبل قليل هنا
في مدينه اضنه في هذا الموقع يبدو ان
عمليات ازاله الركام في مراحلها الاخيره
لذلك نرى سيارات الاسعاف هنا قد قدمت الى
هذا المكان تحسبا لوجود اي
ناجن ربما على قيد الحياه رغم حقيقه يعني
مع دخولنا اليوم الرابع او بعد دخولنا
اليوم الرابع بساعات
يبدو ان فرص الوصول الى ناجين قد تبدو
ضئيله نوعا ما لكن حتى حتى هذه النسب
الضئيله السلطات التركيه تتمسك بها يعني
الكاميرا تستطيع ان ترصد كل سيارات
الاسعاف الموجوده هنا في هذا الشارع
امامنا هنا فرضا اربع سيارات اسعاف وايضا
في الشارع المجاور سيارات اسعافه في
الشارع الخلفي هناك مجموعات من سيارات
الاسعاف الاخرى لذلك يعني هذا يوحي بان
فرق الانقاذ حتى هذا حتى هذه اللحظه ورغم
مرور وقت طويل على وقوع هذه الكارثه الا
انهم ما يزالون يتمسكون بامل العثور على
اشخاص ناجين لذلك الاطقم الطبيه في حاله
استنفار مستمره مع دخول او مع مرور وقت
على دخول اليوم الرابع
الجهود في اقصى مستوياتها نستطيع ان نقول
هنا في ولايه اضنه طبعا قبل ان اكون معكم
في المباشر يعني
اللحظه مدينه الحقيقه معكم مع الساده
المشاهدين هذه الصور المباشره من غازي عنت
هي محاوله
لربما انتشال احدى الجثث او ربما انتشال
احد النادي الناجين لا ندري حتى الان لكن
هناك عمليه يقوم بها
نعم اذا هو ناجن الان تاكد ان هناك ناجم
تم انقاذه في هذه اللحظه في منطقه غازي
عنتاب في مدينه البستان اذا في التابعه
لغاز عنتاب محاوله اذا لاسعاف هذا الناجي
الذي تم اخراجه من بين الانقاض في اليوم
الرابع لهذه الكارثه التي حلت بتركيا ايضا
نشاهد ايضا عمال الانقاذ ورجاء
الاسعافهمون
الاسعافات الاوليه
لهذا النادي في سعي وفي محاوله ايضا لنقله
الى المستشفى في اقرب وقت هناك العديد من
السيارات الاسعاف التي تنتظر في هذا المقر
بطبيعه الحال
وقد نجحت فرق
قد نجحت فرق اذا الاغاثه في انتشال هذا
الناجي او هذا الشخص من هذه المنطقه بعد
اربعه ايام استطاع ان يبقى فيها على قيد
الحياه رغم هذه الظروف الصعبه فرق الانقاذ
المشاهدين ايضا ما زالت تواصل جهودها في
مختلف المناطق التركيه قبل ان كان يتحدث
الرئيس التركي ريب طيب اردوغان كما تابعنا
وتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد زلزال الى 14 الف في
تركيا وتحدثت عن اعاده الاعمار للمناطق
المنكوبه وان هناك ايضا من يسع الاستقلال
هذه الازمه لحصن مكاسب سياسيه اذا هذه
الاحداث تتفاعل بشكل
متتابع في تركيا عمليات الانقاذ تتواصل
وكما نشاهد الان عمليات الانقاذ تنجح في
انتشال هذا الشخص من تحت ركام هذا المبنى
بعد اربعه الايام من الزلزال اذا كما
نشاهد على الخبر العاجل مشاهدينا في تركيا
انقاذ شخص من تحت الانقاض بعد اربعه ايام
في كهرمان منعش كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا في
الاغاثه ايضا التركيه كانت قد احصت انهيار
قرابه سته الاف
واربعمائه واربعه واربعين مبنى في العديد
من المدن التركيه وما زالت اعداد كبيره
بسكانها
لقينا تحت انقاضها حتى هذه اللحظه جهود
الانقاذ هذه ايضا تتزامن مع هزاد ارتداديه
مختلفه وعنيفه ربما بلغت اعداده حتى هذه
اللحظه اكثر من 1200 هزه اعتداديه منذ
زلزالي فجر الاثنين بحسن ما اعلنت اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه التي اكدت ايضا
وقوع هزات ارتداديه اليوم في مدينتي
انطاكيا وفي اهرامان مرعش التركيه
نتابع منها هذه الصور
التي تظهر
حاولت انقاذ هذا الشخص وليس تم انقاذه
بالفعل من تحت ركام هذا المبنى ويتوجه به
الان الى
اقرب وحده طبيه او اقرب مستشفى
هناك ما يبعث بالتاكيد هذه الصور وهذه
هذا التصفيق والفرح الذي نشاهده على
الشاشه يبعث حاله من الامل في
امكانيه ايجاد المزيد من الناجين او
العالقين تحت ركام هذه الابنيه في هذا
التوقيت الصعب جدا الذي تعيشه تركيا
وتعيشه ايضا مناطق في سوريا الان مشاهدينا
دعونا ان نستمع الى هذه الصور بصوتها
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
ده مشاهدينا كمان نتابع حالنا من الفرح في
هذه المنطقه بعد النجاح فرق الانقاذ في
انقاذ شخص من تحت الانقاض بعد اربعه ايام
في منطقه قهرمان مرعش في تركيا
ويتوجه به الان ويبدو حتى الان مبدئيا هو
بصحه جيده يتوجه به الى اقرب مستشفى او
وحده مركزيه عمليه نقاط ما زالت متواصله
مشاهدينا بحثا عن ناجين بين انقاض هذه
المباني التي تعرضت للانهيار الكلي او
الجزئي بفعل زلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا
وشمال غرب سوريا صباح الاثنين بقوه بلغت 7
درجات فاصله ثمانيه كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا
تدخل يومها الرابع
وتتضائل تدريجيا في العثور على ناجين كما
افادت المعلومات الوارده من مناطق الكارثه
لكن ما نشاهد الان على الشاشه يبعث هذه
الاعمال من جديد من ان هناك من يمكنه
الصمود في ظل هذه الظروف الصعبه تحت
ركام هذه الانقاض وهذه المباني كما ذكرنا
مشاهدينا الحصيله الاجماليه لعدد القتلى
في البلدين تجاوزت 17 الفا وخمسمائه قتيل
وفق حصيله جديده هي ايضا للاسف غير نهائيه
كما ان هناك مخاوف من استمرار عداد القتلى
في الارتفاع بهذه الوتيره السلطات التركيه
اعلنت قبل قليل على لسان الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان عن ارتفاع عدد القتلى حتى
الان في تركيا الى اربعه عشر الفا قتيل
نعود مره اخرى مشاهدينا الى اضنه وزيدان
العربيه زيدان كنت معي قبل قليل واعتذر عن
المقاطعتك حديثنا ايضا عن مشاهداتك وما
الذي
تحظى به المناطق من الاولويه يعني هناك
تركيا مساحتها واسعه جدا نتحدث عن خريطه
متراميه الاطراف لكن هل تحظى بعض المناطق
زيدان بالاولويه عن غيرها
نعم احمد بالضبط يعني كما ذكرت المساحه
واسعه جدا والمساحه التي ضربها الزلزال
واسعه جدا كما ذكر محمود قبل قليل يعني
تقديم المساعدات لمساحات جغرافيه كبيره
لمناطق يقطنها على الاقل اكثر من 13 مليون
هي هذا امر يتطلب جهود كبيره ليس فقط جهود
من الحكومه التركيه او من تركيا كدوله
انما جهود من دول اخرى ومساعدات من دول
اخرى يعني رغم كل
كل الاحصائيات او كل الدعم الذي وصل يعني
نتحدث فقط عن طواقم الانقاذ ليس ليس عن كل
الطواقم العامله في مجال في هذه العمليه
تقريبا بلغ 25 الف منهم 5000 هم من
الاجانب من الطواقم الاجنبيه بعموم كل
الطواقم ما بين عمال اغاثه وايضا منقذين
وطواقم طبيه ومن يقدمون الدعم
ومن يقدمون الدعم لمراكز لواء المقدسه
اكثر من 100 الف وبالتالي يعني الاعداد
مقارنه هذه الاعداد مقارنه بحجم الدمار
الكبير يعني اعتقد انها لا تلبي مطلوب
اكثر من ذلك وطبعا كل الدول سواء
المساعدات القادمه او حتى الحكومه التركيه
تحاول تامين المزيد لكن كما ذكرت حجم
الكارثه جدا جدا كبير ومن خلال جوله قمت
بها قبل قليل في مدينه اضنه اعتقد ان
الاثار التي ستنكشف بعد ازاله الركام هي
اكبر بكثير يعني في هذه المدينه رغم ان
اعداد المنازل المدمره والمباني المدمره
اقل بكثير من بقيه الولايات لكن خلال
الجوله التي قمت بها اكتشفنا ان هناك
عشرات المباني الغير صالحه للسكن احمد
وبالتالي هذا يتطلب اما اعاده هدمها او
ترميمها خلال الفتره الماضيه وبالتالي
هناك ازمه سكن ستكون في عموم
الولايات عنه الرئيس التركي قبل قليل
زيدان تحدث عنه اليوم تحدث امس ايضا اعاده
الاعمار وقال انها لن تدوم لاكثر من لن
تستغرق اكثر من عام واحد يعني هل
لهذه التصريحات صدى بين
المواطنين الاتراك ومتضررين تحديدا
لا شك اليوم يعني هذه التصريحات ربما تعطي
بارقه امل لكن اليوم يعني في ظل الظروف
التي يعيشها السكان الذين ولهم يعني اعتقد
ان هذه المده يعني ستكون هم الذين يعيشون
هذه المحنه وهم اكثر الناس شعورا بالاسى
نتيجه اولا
اضطرارهم لخروجهم من بيوتهم وايضا
اضطرارهم
للمكوث في مراكز مؤقته حينما تجهز منازل
مؤقته اخرى اليوم نتحدث عن من هم في
المخيمات او من احضرت لهم افاد المخيم
الخيم هؤلاء لن يبقوا في هذه القيم لمده
سنه سيكون لبعض الفتره وجيزه ثم ينتقلون
الى مباني مؤقته اخرى الى حين ان تؤمن لهم
الحكومه سكن اضافي لا شك هناك حاله من
الحزن الشديد تنتاب الجميع لكن يعني في
مثل هذه الحالات يعني لا يمكن الا ان يكون
هناك صبر على
الوعود الحكوميه في حال تم الموضوع بسنه
كما قال الرئيس التركي هو حقيقه انجاز
كبير اذا تم الموضوع هذا هذا الموضوع خلال
عام لان حجم المنازل المدمره كبير جدا جدا
احمد نتحدث فقط المنازل المدمره حتى هذه
اللحظه
6400 تجاوز الاعداد اذا تحدثنا عن المنازل
المعرضه لانهيار الرقم اكثر من ذلك بكثير
جدا احمد نعم طيب الملاحظه ايضا زيدان ان
الرئيس التركي يركز على نقطه مهمه في
خطاباتي خلال هذه الايام يتحدث دائما عن
مروي الاشاعات وعن ناشرين اكاذيب بحسب ما
يصفهم عرفنا على ذلك يعني هل تلعب
الاشاعات دورا سلبيا واضحا في تاذيب
الاوضاع واثاره القلق بين الناس حاليا في
تركيا
[موسيقى]
نعم لا شك خصوصا عندما نتم الحديث عن هزات
ارتداديه او زلزال قادم من هذا الموضوع
كان منتشر بشكل كبير خلال اليوم الاول
واليوم الثاني لوقوع الكارثه بعض الحسابات
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كانت تثير
الذعر هنا يعني مثلا في غازي عنتاب كان
حديث عن زلزال مدمر في الساعه التاسعه من
اليوم الاول في هاتاي هناك كان سيناريوهات
مشابهه ايضا هذا يعني هذا جانب من الروايه
التي كانت تثير الشائعات والهلع والخوف
هناك جانب اخر يتحدث مثلا عن نقص في
الامدادات والتنظيم في بعض المناطق ونقص
المساعدات وايضا يتهم السلطات بعدم ارسال
المساعدات الكافيه او تعمد ارسال
المساعدات الى مناطق دون اخرى وهناك طبعا
من هاجم مؤسسه الجيش او او وزاره الدفاع
التركي
والمؤسسات التابعه لذلك يعني الرئيس
التركي كان يتحدث عن تحديدا عن الشق
الاخير الذي تحدثت عنه من هو ينتقدون
مؤسسات الجيش لتقصيرها او مؤسسه وزاره
الدفاع والدرك والشرطه للتقصير وعدم
الوصول وارسال مساعدات كافيه
التكافل الاجتماعي ايضا كان حاضرا بقوه
خلال هذه الازمه في تركيا بحسب بعض التقيه
شاهدنا وتابعناها زيدان ما هي مشاهدته
ايضا في هذا في هذه الجزئيه
حاضر وبقوه جدا احمد هذا موضوع لا يمكن
انكاره بالعين المجرده عدا المنظمات
المجتمعيه ومنظمات المجتمع المدني وعدا عن
اجود الحكوميه نحن نتواجد هنا في هذه
المنطقه منذ ثلاثه ايام تقريبا هذا اليوم
الثالث
مواطن عادي يشتري مثلا
كميات كبيره من الماء وياتي بتوزيعها على
المقيمين هنا سواء كان سواء كانوا من
طواقم الانقاذ سواء كانوا من الهلال
الاحمر التركي او حتى من الصحفيين اخرين
يحضرون بعض الحلويات يوم امس تم توزيع
الحيوانات على بعض الموجودين هنا من قبل
اشخاص اما صنعوها في المنزل او حاولوا
شرائها من مكان اخر علما ان الاماكن هنا
غير يعني بعض المتاجر او كثير من المتاجر
لم تفتح ابوابها بعد يعني هناك صعوبه حتى
في تامين هذه المستلزمات اخرون يحضرون بعض
الاغطيه او بعض الالبسه لمن يشاهدونهم في
الشارع وهم بدون ماوى يعني
كيف يتم استقبالها كيف هو وقع وصولها ايضا
على النفوس الاتراك في هذه الظروف الصعبه
يعني اليوم عدا عن الفرق
الاغاثيه يعني انا يوم امس كنت اتحدث مع
احد الاشخاص الذي لديه عائله هنا تحت
الانقاض وكان يتحدث لي عندما قال حقيقه ان
حاله التضامن التي ابدتها عديد الدول
والكثير من الدول وذكر على وجهه تحديد
الدول الاسلاميه التي ابدت هذا التعاطف
الكبير مع الشعب التركي اب يعني اثر
ايجابا في النفوس وقال طالما ان هناك
اشخاص في العالم ما زالوا يؤمنون
بالاخوه
والروابط الاخويه هذا شيء مشجع نعم رغم
المصيبه ان اتحدث عنه هنا انقل بامانه ما
سمعته من الرجل المسن حتى اننا صورنا
مقابله معه على ضمن تقرير على ما اظن بثته
قناه العربيه هذا الصباح يعني لكن هذا ما
قال لي خارج نطاق التصوير وخارج بعدما
انهينا المق يعني كان ممتنا لحجم التضامن
وهذه حاله ايضا طبعا اظن انها موجوده عندك
عند كثير او غالبيه الاتراك الذين خصوصا
الذين يعانون من البقاء بدون ماوى وتفصلهم
مساعدات من عديد الدول
لذلك تكتفي بهذا القدر معك شكرا جزيلا لك
ولزملاء ايضا على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل تحياتي زيدان
تتواصل مشاهدينا جهود فرق الانقاذ بمدينه
هاتايا الاكثر تضرا في تركيا من الزلزال
تتواصل الانتشار العالقين تحت ركام
المباني المتهاويه فيما يفترش الناجون
الارض وامالهم معلقه على نجاح عمليه
الانقاذ في اخراج احياء من تحت الانقاض
وفضل العربي عمار الهندي يرصد الوضع من
هاتاي
نحن وسط مدينه هاتايا التي تتصدر قائمه
المدن والولايات التركيه الاكثر دمارا من
جراء الزلزال هذا هو المشهد هنا في هاتاي
فرق الانقاذ تتوافد وتعمل على مدار الساعه
تسابق الزمن بحثا عن ناجين هنالك ايضا من
يفترش الارض لانه فقد بيته ولم يعد يمتلك
اي شيء وهذه مساعدات تاتي الى هنا تباعا
من متبرعين ياتي المحتاج وياخذ ما يريد من
غذاء وطعام وحتى البس
وهنالك ايضا في المقابل عمليات بحث تجري
على مدار الساعه في كل لحظه بحثا عن
ناجينا تحت الانقاض ومثال على هذا الذي
يحدث هنا في هاتاي ويتكرر في كل مكان هنا
ما يحدث في هذه البنايه حيث يتم البحث
الان بعمليه دقيقه وبطيئه عن شخص يعتقد
انه لا يزال على قيد الحياه تحت الانقاض
امكانيات بسيطه من بسبب
انتشار الدمار في كل مكان في هذه الولايه
ولكن مع بدء اليوم الثالث للزلزال الا
تزال محاولات العثور على الناجين مستمره
لقناتي العربيه والحدث عمار الهندي هاتاي
نذكر مشاهدينا بالخبر العجل الذي اتبعناه
قبل قليل نقل عن المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان الذي يقول فيه ان فصائل مواليه
لتركيا شمال غرب سوريا
هذه التغطيه مستمره مشاهدينا يلتقيهم بعد
قليل الزميل خالد مدخلي في امان الله